all right guys
bang bang i am super excited to have
richard here
uh you got lots of stuff going on man
thank you so much for taking the time to
do this
thanks for having me on pump it's great
to be here
absolutely um let's just jump right in
on background
uh you now run uh what i think has
become
um kind of one of the most noteworthy
crypto exchanges
but uh before that you had a whole
nother life in like the legacy finance
world
uh and so you cut your teeth there talk
a little bit just about you know what
you did
uh where you grew up and then how did
you eventually get into crypto
yeah so i grew up in traditional finance
as you said mainly in the derivative
product set
so i was derivatives and convertible
bonds i was uh
started off as effectively a prop trader
in london so running bank risk
and then moved that into flow and then
slowly moved into market making
and trading around that and uh
then i moved out into tokyo to run uh
distribution
for namura um we were selling
convertible bonds
and then that was around the time that
lehman got acquired
by namura so we brought lehman into the
fold
lehman came with a lot of derivative
product and so
just added that to what we're doing
that's then we renamed the group
multi-strategy sales
so by the end of my career with nomura i
was running
derivatives convertible bonds futures
and options delta one
sort of everything in the derivative
space for distribution across
asia product but across the world
it and so uh there are a number of deals
that you worked on
uh that are um you know years ago but
still
uh i think people kind of look and say
wow that was kind of a seminal uh moment
one of those was this softbank
convertible bond talk a little bit about
kind of just how that deal came together
you know and kind of your experience and
actually running a lot of the
distribution for it
yeah so that was actually a really
challenging deal um
because you couldn't get credit
for softbank at that point in time and
so
credit is a big part of the pricing of a
convertible bond
and so our bankers had actually gone
ahead with the pricing
and just put a random credit number in
there assuming that there was a credit
market
so we then had a situation at the last
hour where there was no credit
and we had to effectively get the credit
desk to help us out and
make some sort of a market but it was it
was a big deal it was 1.5 billion u.s
uh came with an equity tranche as well
but this was a convertible bond
um so yeah it was one of the most hectic
deals i've ever run
but yeah it was good fun and obviously
as you say softbank huge name
very important these days and uh
particularly what they've been doing in
nasdaq
yeah and what's so interesting to me i
think about a deal like that is you know
most people are saying oh softbank today
right but it was still a big deal
then and if this was in the early 2000s
this was kind of
after uh they had had this like meteoric
rise and then
kind of the the suffering of pain uh
during the uh the dot-com
bust as well right yeah well actually if
you look up massason's wikipedia page
he's the person who's lost like the most
money ever
and then made it all back again um so
yeah he's
he's a he's a legend obviously in tokyo
and you know when i was there he
he bought all of vodafone japan and then
pivoted softbank into a telecom
company um so yeah it's a very special
company it's been around for a long time
been doing very aggressive things um
made a load of money with the internet
and now doing it again in tech
in size absolutely and talk a little bit
um kind of how did you go from that
which uh
is pretty traditional and and um
obviously a great business but but just
uh
has nothing to do with crypto or uh tech
really
uh to today running um you know what
what is turning into like this holding
company or conglomerate of different
uh digital asset related products and
services
like when did you first see bitcoin or
crypto and kind of what what pulled you
uh down the rabbit hole if you will well
actually when i first saw it
it was uh it was in 2009.
i had two kids from lehman on my desk
and they were just always talking about
bitcoin i was like guys just sell some
derivatives for god's sake
and uh they were uh you know just
thought about bitcoin i was like
why are you talking about this stupid
internet money like it's a scam clearly
you know
there's there's nothing to be done here
well those two kids are retired now
so um they're in different situation but
uh
yeah i didn't hear about bitcoin again
until all the way until 2017.
uh i read the book sapiens i'd been
really focused on hedging or protecting
wealth against what i was seeing
happening in response to the global
financial crisis around
printing of money i was very very
concerned about what this was doing and
you could you could just see it damaging
everything in terms of
everything in this sort of high-end
space so sort of education
you know holidays medical everything
that was sort of
supply constrained was just going up in
price
to a ridiculous degree even if cpi was
staying
fairly stable because of obviously you
know everything that we were seeing in
tech
and also demographic change as well and
so
yeah it just really became an obsession
of mine a lot of people on the desk were
buying a lot of gold
i was buying gold um and then i read the
the book sapiens at the end at the
beginning of 2017
and yuval is is talking a lot about
bitcoin and blockchain and how
it has the capacity to change the way
that we think about money
um and you know this is all built on his
beliefs around you know money being a
belief system and much of
society being a belief system and so i
started looking into it
and then i actually invested in this
company diginex
which back then was a cryptocurrency
mining company
so with gpu mining they were mining
ethereum
and um yeah i became an investor and
then when i left banking
the founder asked me to come and help
him build the company further i was like
i don't know what you're going to need
me for to build a mining company
he's like no no you don't understand i
think there is a huge
opportunity around disrupting
traditional finance with this tech
and so then i obviously caught my
attention we sat down we talked about it
thrashed it out
sort of built the strategy for what is
diginex today
which is you know a full ecosystem as
you say a conglomerate
around this space that covers everything
from exchange from trading
to custody to asset management and
actually it's an investment bank
got it and so as you think through um
kind of where you sit today let's just
start at a high 10 000 foot
view of there's so many different
products and services that you could
go into um maybe give us an overview of
like
what are you guys doing uh and then talk
about kind of the
why like why are you pursuing those
versus you know the hundreds of other
things that you could be doing with your
time
money and resources sure absolutely
i mean i think you know a lot of what
we're
about is you know you have a very
similar philosophy it's about
making the migration from institutional
investors into this
technology and asset class and i think
when you think about that and the way
that these institutions are set up
the starting point always is going to be
custody
right you need to have a custody that
can be trusted it can be secure
and it's viable right now you know there
hasn't been a major hack for such a long
time that people are just
not that concerned about custody but
institutions always will be
and so we had a look at a lot of the
custody offerings on the street
and we actually acquired one um but then
we
we just got to the point we're like look
there there's nothing that we really can
rely on to the degree that we need
um so we hired a team that's led by
uh an ex-ministry of defense
security specialist um and they they
built out what today is digital from one
of the most secure
um and solid offerings on the street i
often describe
the cold custody as as below freezing
because it's just you know it's actually
operated out of
global volts of the vault provider
malcolm it
so you can you can set up a ball
anywhere in the world
and specify that's where you you want
your your keys kept
so that's sort of the foundation and the
the sort of where everything else is
able to be built from
at the center of it all is our exchange
equos
so equos is really focused and you know
there's loads of exchanges out there so
why have another one
and i think the big important point here
is
that we've built differentiated product
in the fact that we have infrastructure
that a
is able to accommodate these
institutions that are coming in i'll
give you a basic example
right now you log on to any exchange
even if you go with the
the pro version or the institutional
version you get one login for your
account
right that's non-manageable for an
institution when they come in
they need to have segregation of duty
they need to have their ops team
their trading team their compliance team
their audit team
all to have different access and
different ways that they can access that
account
and so that's basic stuff the stuff that
we've built into the framework
of equos to allow that first step of
institutions to come in another thing is
managed accounts so think about the the
asset management industry in this space
at the moment it's quite nascent
right many of the asset managers and we
have an asset manager
that we speak to because we're a fund of
funds
they don't understand that they need to
have separate custody
to be investible by institutions right
they don't understand how they should be
marking their books they've got icos
still marked at
2017 prices because they've never traded
you know so they like there's a lot
wrong with the way that
current asset management landscape works
and so we built a thunder fund really to
help develop that
but also when you think about that in
the context of the exchange
actually provide a service to those
funds of managed account
functionality like we see in traditional
finance so you know your
new york pension fund that you you got
to come into bitcoin you get
get them to go and allocate to a
strategy within that but say okay you
can run it through a
regulated platform where you know your
assets are safe
you know if they drift off mandate that
you can pull them off it
and actually you can you can really have
proper control
over that strategy much like we do in
the in the hedge fund industry today
post 2008
now a lot a lot of the allocations are
made by managed accounts through prime
brokers
so the exchange is really designed to
give that
institutional capacity to really grow
this industry
and really grow the asset management
industry as well but then when we think
about retail i mean because it's not
just an institutional platform it's
about
making sure that we can have everyone
participate
so obviously for retail we want to make
sure that people are looked after
fairly a lot of you know the experience
that people have on some of these
platforms is
they now they get ripped off or their
fees are too high or
they get the uh liquidations happening
of some of the lev
products and you know very very much
against them
um and so you know everything that we've
designed is about
making sure we're fair we're transparent
um and obviously that we've got that
product innovation
that really allows people to to to
manage their portfolios in a way that
that this this technology allows
because you you know you look at
everything that we've got we've got
you've got bitcoin as an asset right
you you can just sit in your cold
custodian
or you can start to trade derivatives
around that position
to maximize the value within the
portfolio but you can also lend it
as well as collateral and actually
receive fees for it
so actually it's starting to take
finance into your own hands
and be able to really build around that
core
collateral of bitcoin with other
products
and that's the longer term vision of
what we're doing aircross putting it all
together
where you've got a really nice ecosystem
to allow you to really manage your
assets properly
so this starts to look very similar to
what the traditional world did with
fiat currency based assets right and it
almost feels like what you're trying to
do
and doing pretty well is recreating all
of the things that we know that work in
the traditional world in terms of a
product suite and kind of how those
interact with each other
now just redoing it for digital assets
do you think that's a fair
uh categorization um and maybe talk a
little bit about
uh there are a couple of wrinkles or
changes there but and kind of how you
decide
when do you follow the traditional
playbook versus when you kind of you
know
go rogue and create a new crypto way to
do something
yeah like it's um yeah it's very valid
and we are looking at everything that
we've learned from traditional finance
and and bringing it to this industry to
help really
uh grow the industry and make it
properly adopted
so for example derivatives so
derivatives are a huge focus of us i'm a
derivative guy
the original founders derivative guy our
chairman's a derivative guy
i mean everybody within the senior part
the management of the organization on
the product side
is a derivative guy so
we're very focused on effectively
building that out
allowing the options market to really
grow
and then when you have as you know a
full
options market of every strike in every
every uh
every maturity then you can start to
build things like fixed products
suddenly the whole thing becomes a lot
more edible you can start to build
things like variants and
structured products and all these types
of things structured products obviously
feeds the volatility into the market
and then you you've got all these
products that institutions want to play
with
right and want to be able to manage that
portfolio risk around
so for us derivatives is a very core
part of as you say bringing that
institutional level of finance
into this industry and going okay we've
started with that perpetual product
everything else is quite nascent and we
really need to start to grow it out
to to allow this industry to hit the
sort of numbers
that we see in traditional finance but
right now
the spot market of cryptos i don't know
it's four billion dollars a day that it
trades
and then you've got derivatives is
another 12 to
14 depending on the day so on a good day
you can have a
20 billion market but the ribs is only
really three
four times the market in traditional
effects you know derives is
over 100 times the spot market so the
the capacity for growth there is
enormous
and we're right at the beginning and
obviously derivatives have grown
quite significantly over the last couple
of years but uh we really think that's
going to continue and that's really
where we focus the opportunity set
now for the business but then the other
part is our investment bank itself
and that's more down the line so
we've taken a slightly different
approach to many of the other guys that
are offering digital securities in this
space or security tokens as they called
um and rather than enforce on
investors that they take a digital
security
because that immediately wipes out like
95
of any institutional investor because
they're just not going to get it through
risk or product committee is we actually
deliver
our assets in paper form with the option
when they're ready to take it in digital
so they can flip it into a digital
security in the future
now obviously that that's helpful to us
as well because we don't have the
correct licensing
at this point for the exchange to allow
us to list
securities and we don't yet have the
correct license for the custodian either
although we do have all the
infrastructure there already
around the different standards of
ethereum that we're seeing the majority
of these tokens being built on
but yeah it's it's about licensing so a
big
big
drawback always is is the pace of
regulation
around this um so yeah those are
probably the two
key areas is the derivative market and
then the
the digital security market and so when
you think of that digital security
market
um you know i am one of uh of many
people who believe that that is going to
be
very very large right um i think that a
lot of people
uh including myself thought that that
was going to be uh kind of on the equity
side first right so this idea of like
every stock bond currency commodity will
eventually be digitized
uh we'll start on the equity side uh it
feels like actually where a lot of that
is starting
is on the debt side right so we've seen
all all kinds of different debt
issuances
uh on ethereum we're big investors in a
company called figure that has figured
out how to do this
um as kind of a digital um you know
kind of dtcc uh but the equity side
uh hasn't really taken off yet and so
kind of maybe talk a little
bit about why that may be and then you
know is that buying you guys extra time
to kind of really get positioned to
capitalize when it happens or kind of
how you're thinking about
your positioning in the market as these
digital securities kind of um you know
fulfill the promise that we've kind of
talked about for two years or so
yeah look i think uh you've got very
large private credit markets
right the the it's the private markets
that are the most impacted by this
because suddenly you've got a technology
can that can make it much more
transactable
you can embed documentation into the
asset itself
which you know when you're dealing with
a private asset there's
there's not so much transparency always
around the documentation that you're
dealing with
now equities is slightly different you
know we have public equity markets
um and the private equity markets are
quite robust at the moment we talk about
softbank obviously
huge checks flying around and a lot of
liquidity in those markets
so i think it's really on the outer
edges where liquidity suffers somewhat
we're seeing um the most impact so fixed
income and private credit is obviously
um it's it's a little bit of an easier
avenue
we're actually most focused on
securitizations
so we actually um are looking at
securitization of a private equity fund
uh the lp of that of that fund um
and we're we've been working on a number
of property transactions so
you know when you hear about
tokenizations of buildings they're
effectively a securitization
right so our investment bank is a
securitization advisory firm
um and so i guess where we differ
to the majority of other folks out there
not to figure i mean that's obviously a
different
product all together but um
you know a majority of the platforms are
really about delivering the technology
and just allowing you to issue that
token
uh whereas we we provide the full front
to back so from
right to the advisory how do i structure
this
through to the actual delivery of the
security which as i said you know we
deliver
majority of times in paper form at this
point but
we expect more and more to see that
delivered in digital
you know it's almost like you end up
just building the muscle memory of doing
the securitizations
today you use the the kind of more
traditional technology but over time
you'll you'll convert that to the
uh the digital technology right yeah i
think it's
it's really hard to to say go jump in
that pond
it's you know it's a it's a different
experience altogether
to an investment manager you go to a
japanese pension fund and you say
why don't you guys invest in a in a
digital security and they're going to be
like
what's the digital security they're like
well blockchain
okay i've heard of bitcoin what's the
blockchain
okay so you can explain and then what
standard and then
well how do i book this and how do i
custodia and where does it trade
and it just becomes too hard so you're
not going to get to that
point immediately and i think that's a
mistake that a lot of people make
is that they get sort of over
enthusiastic about what the technology
can do and how it's going to change
everything
but it's an iterative process and you
have to build to that point
because you're dealing with people that
are in very traditional frameworks
have to go through a risk committee um
have to get it through their ic
so make it as easy as possible give them
the option down the line when
when they can actually get to the point
saying oh hang on we bought that
paper security off the diginex guys two
years ago
maybe we could use that to experiment
with this technology and then slowly
slowly you're building
a base of people that can adopt it
quicker in the future
yeah it makes uh makes a lot of sense uh
you are uh not standing still
as uh as you guys are building this
business from a capital market
standpoint
uh you recently raised a a private round
uh about 20 million dollars uh and then
you
are going through this spac transaction
getting into
a nasdaq listing talk a little bit just
how you thought about
capitalizing the business and why some
of these decisions over the last kind of
you know three to six months or so
yeah sure i mean look we we raised the
private round because
with everything that was going on with
kovid nothing was sure
um so we were just like look we'd better
just make sure that we've got
at least an initial base for for what we
need to get
to keep uh getting to the point where we
uh we can deliver everything
um but you know we always had our eye on
that nasdaq listing
um for us it was essential uh
for the industry and for ourselves to
give that additional layer of trust
and credibility when you're walking into
a room and talking about
this technology i'm sure you've had it
many times we're just like yeah
yeah i can't look at that but when
you're when you're coming at it from a
nasdaq listed company's perspective okay
hang on a minute um i want to maybe want
to pay a bit more attention
the other thing is about the credibility
of the exchange as well
i had a lot of commentary from people
that wanted to invest in bitcoin but
have heard these horror stories about
quadriga
or exchange hacks or whatever and it's
just like
i've never felt comfortable sending
money
to one of these places you know finally
there's you know there's a company
that's going to be a nasdaq listed
exchange that i can send my money to and
have that level of comfort
that uh they're not going to just
disappear and pretend they're dead or
whatever that guy did
absolutely and in terms of uh the public
markets
it feels like uh there's just not that
many
um kind of ways to get exposure to
digital assets
right so you've got maybe kind of a
square which is doing a lot of bitcoin
uh facilitating bitcoin purchases you've
got now kind of micro strategy who's
actually holding bitcoin
uh maybe there's uh some others that are
kind of tangentially related
but there's not really um kind of hey
that is a digital asset
ticker that i can buy that is pure
exposure to that right maybe get some
mining stocks or whatever but nothing
that's kind of a dead-on
um exposure walk me through kind of the
logic between
uh what you think the impact of you guys
getting into the public market in that
manner uh
is gonna be and then two is uh the
advantage or disadvantage kind of pros
and cons of being the first
versus maybe wanting to be you know fast
follower number two or three and let
somebody else be the first
yeah look for us it was it was always
just about
making sure that we got there um and so
we never anticipated that we'd be the
first we figured that uh
many many people would be trying to do
this because i mean let's be honest the
industry has suffered from credibility
issues for
quite some time and so you know if we
want to make this institutional then we
have to be able to give someone that
sort of
element of trust where we go okay now
this is a company that's
you know past nasdaq listing
requirements
sec approved you know that's a it's a
proper organization
i think to your point around having a
proper play
into this space in the public markets is
is also really important
um you've got obviously like you
mentioned microstrategy but i met an etf
uh guy who's he's got a blockchain etf
met him uh
back in march in new york and uh he said
i'm having a nightmare allocating this
fund you know i i'm allocating to
facebook because they might do libra
or i'm allocated to ibm because they got
hyper ledger
he's like this is you know i need a
proper pure play
so you know we're obviously the picks
and shovels to the
industry you've got people like
grayscale that that have these
these tracker funds directly into the
asset but we're everything around it
with the ecosystem play and i think
that's
like you say it's it's quite
differentiated anyway as a business
model
um but being able to play it by the
public markets i think is
is uh is quite an opportunity got it
and so you're obviously going to now be
in this new position of
publicly traded uh you've got capital on
the balance sheet
where does the focus go now is it just
more of the same and kind of go faster
and further
is there new things that are kind of on
the horizon from a product and
kind of services standpoint like how do
you think about moving forward
yeah look we've we've always got big
goals in terms of what we're doing
um the next phase for our custodian for
example is to implement borrowing and
lending facility
we want to make sure that people can
have that within the exchange
so that they can go back and forth um
you know have it in super cold
but then maybe write a swap short to
effectively be able to
to to provide some sort of derivative
trade or
or lend it out um the exchange itself
is always pushing forward with new
product innovation obviously talks about
that road map for derivatives um and
we've just uh we've just moved ahead
with our investment product business
which will be the start
of having listed vehicles and and notes
issued out of europe for traditional
stock exchanges
and and other exchanges uh where we'll
start to build the structured products
flow effectively you get that derivative
flow coming into the exchange
the other thing is i mentioned the the
asset management side of things really
once you start to get that traction that
that takes time
but building that out building
reputation in the space for
for having assets i mean that's
something that can grow
very exponentially and then obviously
quietly in the background
running the securitization business
that'll continue
yeah and how do you think about uh
balance sheet one of the things i've
seen with a lot of companies both in the
public and private markets who are
interested or touched this
is uh you've got kind of fiat currencies
and then there's this you know digital
asset
and some people uh are religious about
let me convert
bitcoin ether whatever it is into cash
as soon as possible it's easier
for accounting um all of those things
other people
are converting from cash to uh to crypto
as we see with microstrategy where do
you guys sit in terms of
um kind of managing your balance sheet
how do you think about
uh you know maybe not exact numbers but
just like theoretically
uh the balance between that cash and
digital assets
yeah for us you know i mean it's
obviously we're we're moving very very
fast you've said
so in terms of the focus on on managing
that balance sheet to
that that it's not at the degree where
it's significant enough
where someone like a micro strategy or
even an apple sitting on a
a cash pile of that degree they have to
think very carefully about their
inflation edge
you know more and more we're having
people in the organization that want to
be paid
uh in cryptocurrencies so yeah we have
to manage that obviously from a
uh a treasury perspective but yeah i can
i can tell you that it's been the
subject of
of many conversations particularly
expedited by
our friends of microstrategy got it
and then in terms of um zooming out from
just diginex into
the uh crypto community industry
what areas are you kind of paying
attention to are there things that
maybe are not getting as much um you
know uh
air time that you think should be um or
are there things that maybe are
overhyped that you say hey you know what
we're actually not as excited as maybe
other people are like how do you just
think through
other things that are going on yeah i
think
obviously the d5 is the is the big uh
sort of
phase at the moment that everyone's
getting very excited about and
uh you know i do believe that that the
d5
is the future potentially down the road
the way things start to evolve
um but it is it's very early it's like
trying to
fly to the moon in the in a cardboard
box
i mean you you're gonna get yourself
into trouble along the way and you know
things are going to break
and burn up as we've already started to
see so uh
yeah i i definitely have concerns about
what that does
for us on a reputational basis for the
industry as a whole
and i definitely look back to 2017 and
the like uh this d5 thing is probably
not what we need right now you know
we've got micro strategy coming in we've
got paul judy jones coming in we've got
some really
serious hitters starting to pay
attention to this industry and i just
i just hope that d5 doesn't become
another another ico craze that
people go you know what everyone's crazy
in crypto
stay away from it for another few years
uh i'm assuming that you are also
thinking that uh
we are kind of in the early days of
another bull market uh correct me if i'm
wrong on that but also
how does that play into um you guys
being listed
uh some of these other kind of
non-bitcoin type
um you know areas that people are
focused on is this a
kind of all boats rise together do you
think that there is that that uh
you know everyone waiting for the
decoupling is there a flipping i feel
like there's all these you know
kind of theories as to what plays out
you know where in your mind
uh uh do some of these things end up
well you you know i'm a big bitcoin bull
i mean
the reason i got into this industry in
the first place was because
i was looking at an inflation hedge and
so
i'm a big big believer in in bitcoin
i think we're going to see a massive
rally and it's coming very soon i
i often say to people that right now
it's a coiled spring
and it's just coiling tighter and
tighter and tighter and
it's just going to explode to the upside
very very soon
um that said to your question about
you know the high tide rising all boats
i think definitely um
the the debate i was at a debate with a
lot of people in the industry in hong
kong
um a few months ago and there was one
one one person they're saying look
there's no way that we're going to make
the same we're going to see people make
the same mistakes
that we saw in the ico craze and it's
just going to be bitcoin
and everything everything else is just
going to stay stay down
i was like that's just not factual i
mean like there's so many new people
coming into this industry
so many people that don't understand
what bitcoin is
that look at it and go okay what's the
next one and we see it we saw it in 2017
and and i'm getting that question all
the time like bitcoin's too expensive i
don't want to buy it i want to buy the
one that's going to do 1000x
and it's just the nature of the whole
game theory the way satoshi planned it
is that greed is what effectively will
help
with the adoption because when you get
that
cut in supply to the degree we do every
four years
then that's just gonna squeeze the price
very very hard
and so then you get that sort of game
theory element and greed sort of
number go up theory uh around
propagating the
the success of bitcoin but but what
happens around the edge is everyone's
like well
there's got to be another one that's
going to be better than bitcoin because
bitcoin's the old one
i'm sure you've heard this a hundred
times right and i get it i'm like no no
no
you you you've got to buy some bitcoin
sure have have a little
portfolio to muck around with but you
know your main investment is bitcoin
i uh i joke all the time and i tell
people
uh sometimes the simplest trade uh or
the the best trade is the siblish trade
uh but on top of that uh humans want to
gamble
right like that that is ultimately what
it is and you know for everyone who is
you know intellectually honest they say
the stock market is just a legal casino
and that's okay
right i mean you know not knock
yourselves out uh but
there is this element of if you want to
kind of go play in
you know the crypto casino uh to your
point
have the major exposure to bitcoin and
then sure take five
or ten percent of what you want to put
in a crypto and you know go bet it on
black
you'll win half the time and half time
you won't
and frankly i think people are just
paying for entertainment to some degree
rather than
actually trying to generate a financial
return uh and that's okay
right there's no problem with that but
uh but it's pretty funny when you start
to think of it that way
yeah but you know when we next see
bitcoin go up a thousand percent
people are gonna go okay what i've
missed it where's the next one and you
will have this effect
and because these are all smaller market
caps they will probably
outperform to the upside but but the
tiers afterwards are going to be
significantly more to the downside and
so
when you go through that cycle as as
we've already seen many times
then then those those pointless projects
will be uh
will be exposed fully absolutely
talk a little bit about uh some of the
challenges or things that you're
thinking about
uh in terms of uh scaling the business
we've talked a lot about kind of the
products and the services and
kind of the the bowl case if you will
for you guys and for crypto
what are the things that kind of keep
you up at night and you spend a lot of
time just figuring out you know
how do we solve these problems yeah look
i mean we're a very kyc
an aml focused exchange we want to be
compliant we want institutions to know
that they're not going to come onto this
platform and buy bitcoin off a money
launderer or someone that's been
financing terrorism
so we do have strict controls we do have
kyc and ml
and as a result retail often
you know run into uh run into problems
so
we have to be very active in driving
that forward that's one thing that
that i i work on actively with both the
sales team and the marketing team is
making sure
that we've got that plan really mapped
out and making sure that we're always
sort of helping retail on an educational
basis understand what they're dealing
with
but also really making the process a lot
easier as much as possible
but adhering to compliance guidelines as
well
so that's that's probably the the one
thing that does
keep me awake at night uh around the
platform itself
in terms of you know other stuff where
we we've got
i would say probably one of the coolest
institutional
on-ramps to an ecosystem that i've seen
anywhere
in the industry is our trading platform
so we have a trading platform called
diginex access
and access effectively allows you to
trade on
any platform you've got to have your own
login
but it effectively allows you to trade
algos and arbs and spreads across
different
different platforms but the important
thing about this is
this plugs into two of the world's
largest
trading technology providers fis
i'm sure you've heard of fidelity
investment solutions and
activity those two providers alone
cover the large majority of the
institutional finance space
that look at outsourcing their trading
technology
um we plug into both their portfolio
management systems so anybody from any
of those institutions
that wants to start to trade crypto gets
given
access as part of that portfolio
management management system
as their crypto module so this is
huge uh for us in terms of helping again
drive adoption but obviously it's a way
for us to get
you know paid for all the flow that's
going on in the industry
as well as obviously help direct flow
into equos
from these institutions got it makes
makes a lot of sense and they took a
little bit about from a talent
standpoint um obviously
uh you're in hong kong now um how have
you found the market for
uh talent in building up the team is
this something where
you've been able to uh kind of convince
people from the traditional world to
cross over
or most of the people that you're
finding uh just coming right out of the
crypto world already
and just kind of elaborate on that yeah
no sure
so as you probably know hong kong has
quite a rich
crypto uh crypto environment and uh
yeah actually though i don't know if you
saw it actually there was bitcoin
ads that have been put up everywhere
around hong kong now absolutely was that
you guys
see was that you guys actually the big
it was the bitcoin association
okay kudos to them it was a very high
quality move
i loved it um but yeah there's a big
community here and a big focus on the
industry so
obviously we've got that access but also
there's a huge
financial services industry and a lot of
people that
we know from that world that we've been
able to pull over
um to give you an ex example so the guy
the guy we hired to run the investment
products business
i told you we're just launching that now
so that's the
sort of way into structured products as
a guy that we knew from uh from ubs
um ran global structured products for
them
ubs is the biggest structured product
house in the world you know with their
private bank and their asset management
so you know taking their global head of
structured products and moving them into
this industry was quite a cool for us
um but yeah look we're we're a global
business so we hire a lot out of london
um switzerland um as well as hong kong
and now we're building into singapore as
well
so actually with the with the listing
we're moving the company to be a hong
kong
headquartered company um so that's uh
that's obviously an another huge talent
pool around the fintech space
um not so much in crypto as hong kong
um but yeah it's uh it's obviously also
in the traditional finance
one thing i've really found with this
industry is is obviously
you know my own passion when i'm
interviewing people and getting getting
excited about it
um as i'm sure you have you you do when
you speak to people about the asset
class but
even with a much smaller checkbook that
i ever had
to hire people in investment banking um
we're hiring levels of talent you know
way way above
what we were ever able to achieve in
banking
so i think this is really just turning
the heads of some of the most you know
brilliant minds in
in traditional finance as well as
obviously you know
young people that are coming up and
looking at traditional files again
i'm going to go crypto i i tend to think
that you are
you're right there my friend um help me
understand
uh what would change your mind about all
this right so
you know i've started to think more
about um i'm
you know as bullish as anyone uh and
somebody asked me recently what would
change my mind and i had a couple of
ideas but what would change your mind
when it comes to
bitcoin and kind of the bull case for
crypto in general yeah look i think
bitcoin there there are two major
arguments that are pulled out
that do kind of occasionally may
make me sit and wonder and that's
obviously
a government-sponsored uh 51 attack
um and that could only really be
achieved by
someone with big balance sheet so let's
say the fed decided
you know bitcoin is the only threat to
us continuing with this game
of fair money and you know they could
go and you know amass enough hash power
to do a 51
attack and then cause uh cause people to
lose confidence in bitcoin but i just
think it's so unlikely
i don't think they're ever gonna be able
to be considering doing that until
it's at such a point where it's too late
um and you know the the
value of all that printing is probably
not gonna be
sustainable um and then the other thing
is
is quantum computing a lot of people
talk about that
but again i i think you know there's
there's so much around quantum computing
that is yet to be understood
um i think that you know even if someone
was sitting
in their garage developing a quantum
computing to the
computer to the degree that it could
actually launch and work tomorrow
that nobody knew about then the first
thing they
can do is not attack bitcoin
they've got plenty of other things in
their plan and the amount of money they
probably spent uh financing that is
is is going to give them a focus on
other things
so yeah look i those are the two
two big things um how would you think
about those two particular items i'm
sure they're both things that uh
that have come across your mind yeah
look i think both of those are valid
points and
the only third one that i usually add is
uh if literally everyone just walked
away
right right to the point of like there's
almost this feeling of uh yeah
bitcoin's price went to zero like
literally zero
uh then it's over right but even if it
dropped
you know in some weird way to hundreds
of dollars from here
i actually think that there's a lot of
people who would just be buying it up
right and it's kind of this joke of uh
well i know that you know
a government can't buy up all the
bitcoin because they're not buying mine
right right and so uh you know i i just
think that one of the
um greatest assets of uh of the industry
and um of kind of bitcoin specifically
is just this uh community of really
strong
hands that uh this is not just
i hope that the price of an asset goes
up this is a belief
in something that is you know much much
greater than any financial asset and i
think that that's very rare
uh to have those belief systems kind of
tied to something
and that tends to uh to lead to kind of
um
outperformance right you see it with
other kind of stocks where you get
almost like cult-like following
um i think the same thing uh is playing
out here as well
yeah i mean it's did you ever read that
book sapiens
by eval harari i've read like half of it
to be honest so i got this weird thing
where i read uh
i i just don't sit down and read like
one book at a time i kind of read a
little bit i moved to another one
whatever
and i probably wrote about half of it uh
and just
got busy with other things but i enjoyed
uh what i read but i haven't finished it
yeah i mean he he goes on about money
being a belief system
and obviously that's what it is we've
seen it evolve through
throughout time and and like you say i
mean bitcoin has a
cult following already you've already
got 18.8 million
bitcoin out there in probably fairly
steady hands
you don't have much left as more and
more people start to join the game
it's not going down to 100 certainly not
to zero
i don't yeah i don't think that is
is even viable like you say you and i
would buy the whole lot before it got to
zero
so it's it's not happening absolutely
um richard listen what you're doing is
uh i think right now everyone's kind of
like what is what's going on
there's gonna be a crypto company that's
going to get out into the public markets
uh talk a little bit just about you know
20 years from now how do you want people
to remember
uh this time and kind of what you guys
are doing right now
you know i think 20 years from now i
mean we'll be looking back on this
everything will be different um
certainly the financial services
industry
you know we've the public filing of the
presentation that we made
actually talks about how the internet
affected
many other industries obviously retail
being one
with you know amazon just sort of
absolutely carving it up
that's a 25 trillion dollar industry
whereas
you know with capital markets you got
200 trillion dollar
industry and this is going to be
gargantuan when we start to see
companies like ours come in and really
change the face of what's being done
in investment banking and capital
markets and
you know we're doing everything to make
sure that we're positioned right in
front of the center of that
because derivatives is going to be a
core part of it but also being able to
manage your portfolio in a single place
is so much more attractive and then you
can actually as you know move those
assets out and
you know sit there and at a poker game
say
oh well rather than pay you in bitcoin
i'm going to pay you as part of my
property that i just invested in in sao
paulo which got 12 percent yield
and if if uh i've got quite a lot of it
so i can
i can let you have some of that directly
out of my portfolio
and then you know what impact is that
going to have on the asset management
industry
what impact is that going to have on the
401k business
you know as as people say look i just
want to manage everything in one single
place
i'm not american but i understand that
you want to switch your 401k
the amount of paperwork you have to do
is gonna take like 10 days to two weeks
if you're efficient so the idea
of just being able to move an asset to
from one to the other
at the click of a button it it's
gonna change everything um it's gonna
change the way we deal with private
equity
as well um you know look at all the
documentation now you've got companies
like carter
that manage all of that for you you can
now embed cap tables into
you know tokens and you know it can be
all updated live time with documentation
everything this is it's just remarkable
how it's going to transform things and
i'm yeah i'm really excited that diginex
is here now and
20 years from now hopefully you're still
doing a podcast we can have a good chat
about
how the world has changed i'll be old
man
i might have lost my voice by that point
before we get into uh the rapid fire
questions to uh to end this where can
people go find out more about diginex
the exchange and kind of what you guys
are doing
sure so um diginext.com is uh
overall website uh to get onto the
exchange is
equos.io but equos.com will get you
there as well
um we're on twitter so diginext global
at diginext global on twitter
all one word and then at equos
underscore
io for the exchange and then i'm on
twitter as well at richard byworth or
one word
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
i would say sapiens it absolutely
changed the way that i
thought about the world um and certainly
changed my career
almost immediately i read the book i
said right that's it i'm leaving banking
um and uh yeah it took me about eight
eight months to get out of banking it's
a little bit of a uh
a difficult process when you're tied up
in equity and these sorts of things
um but yeah got out in here uh you get
to ask me one question to uh to wrap
this up what uh what one question do you
have for me
so yeah if we uh if we are to meet one
day
uh in new york what uh what what is the
restaurant you're gonna take me to
oh man i i don't know how i've gotten in
this position now but
uh somehow uh people ask me for
recommendations because they know that
i'm like
because i always eat uh dominoes and
mcdonald's and all this crazy stuff
um but no i i think that uh what
there's a couple of restaurants that i
really enjoy um
there's a uh there's a spanish place and
i've got a soft spot my heart for this
guy
uh he's down the street from me he runs
a uh a spanish place called
alcapa i think is how it was pronounced
and uh throughout this entire pandemic i
walk by him every day
uh and he basically gives me updates on
uh
on the um politician's lack of
competence
and he basically will you know we'll say
something to the effect of
literally for months you can go get a
massage but you can't eat my restaurant
this is [ __ ]
right or or he'll hit me with uh i used
to do
80 you know tables per lunch now i do
six this is [ __ ]
and uh and he just cracks yeah you stat
every day
yeah he's just always got some
perspective on you know
this sucks and and he says it with a
smile on his face and he's so jovial
uh and all that so he um uh
he's got great food right but uh but but
i think he i just got like that sweet
spot
in my heart for him uh after you know
literally seeing a month after month
after month saying the same stuff
um and then uh there's all the classics
like
i think most people really like the you
know like 11 madison parks and
and um you know union square cafes and
like those types of places
for me i'm those are less interesting to
me just i think that they're
yeah that's where everyone wants to go i
like going and finding kind of the hole
in the wall places
um yeah that's the best yeah and then
i'll tell you this that there's one
place that i take a lot of people planet
and i
um it's our favorite place to take
people is the uh the jp morgan library
uh in new york which is uh not a
restaurant
um but basically it is uh an
old um you know kind of house slash
office library uh of jp morgan and it's
literally the size of a block
and you go inside and they've done a
pretty good job preserving it
but you just see uh kind of a
you get thrust into this world of the
early 1900s
and it's pretty cool just to realize
like
this was the high society of that time
right
and kind of all the things they have as
part of the actual
uh decor or the the structure of the
building
and you walk in this library uh and it's
basically
everything except for the door you walk
in is all
bookshelves around you it's you know two
or three stories tall
uh filled up there's secret doors so you
can go up the stairs to other bookcases
and
all kinds of crazy stuff and you just
realized like it was all about knowledge
like that's literally all it was right
is they that's why they had the big
library was because they
literally would they didn't have the
internet and they would go and pull a
book and like
learn and look things up and so it's
just kind of a cool experience so when
you come we'll uh
we'll go there and then maybe find uh
find a shitty uh
fast food place right around the corner
done that sounds great i do have one
more question for you
all right so so you did you did
something
quite monumental for the industry you
got you know those two pension funds to
come in and invest effectively directly
in the asset class
how long did that take you and how many
of those calls did you
effectively make to find those
those two investors because that was
impressive
so uh i don't know if i've ever said
this before
um what i will start off by saying is
uh the two cios who made this decision
are incredibly
forward-thinking uh courageous they had
to do a lot of work
uh kind of behind the scenes to make
this happen so it wasn't as easy as just
let me do an asset allocation and like
you know everyone's like oh of course
we're gonna buy stocks
uh this was a lot of work on their part
um
and so they really believed in this
right and so i'll forever be grateful to
them
uh my partners will as well um but but i
i think that uh it'll prove to be pretty
effective
a decision um but but i think that's
kind of the key pieces like
without those two people wanting to do
this this never gets done
um but they had uh they were familiar
with
morgan creek already i don't think that
they had actually ever invested but
they were familiar uh and the crazy part
of the story is uh myself
and one of the sales guys went to go see
them in person in virginia
and in the very first meeting uh one of
the cios said
yeah i'd like to do this and that never
happens right
and so here's here's the crazier part it
was the first institution i ever met
with
wow the very first institution i ever
met with
very first meeting one of the two ci
there's three cios in the room kind of
from all the different pension plans
uh and one of them says i'd like to do
this
and so you know there's still a lot of
work to do whatever but basically kind
of verbally
indicated let's go do that work and
let's get this approved and the second
uh one said uh you know i gotta think a
little bit more and kind of look through
everything but like this is interesting
to me
so i walked out of there i was like
we're gonna raise a gazillion dollars
these people have huge checkbooks and
they're like that's it
uh this is easier than raising money for
your own companies like all kinds of
stuff
and uh the uh the sales guy basically we
didn't even close the door to the room
and he was already like that will never
happen again i've been doing this 30
years you know
like he was trying to like really set
expectations low
and uh uh i said well that's because you
haven't had me
like of course like you know like we're
we're gonna go do this and so uh
i ended up calling um uh mark usco
one of my partners uh afterwards and you
know basically was like
you guys were telling me how hard this
is like this is the easiest thing in the
world like where's the next one
right and uh he didn't believe me he
literally did not believe me that that's
what happened because he was like i've
never even heard
of that happening uh and so he put the
sales guy on the phone the guy's like
dude it does 30 years i've never seen
that before
uh and then in true form you know i went
oh for 30 in the next 30 pitches
right right because it was just like
okay like you got the beginner's luck
out of the way
uh got you excited so um i think there
will be many more
uh but but you know ultimately that
those two
it just comes down to the cios um you
know kind of having
the foresight and uh um
kind of the courage to uh to do it which
is pretty special and
obviously that's epic actually great
story uh yeah
i wasn't aware of that look trust me i
i've already convinced myself i'm gonna
tell that story 20 years from now to
somebody and they're gonna think i'm
lying
right so it's like i'm putting it on the
record and uh
and uh pretty cool experience but but
look i think what you guys are doing
right in terms of being one of the first
uh to get out of the public markets i
think like what michael sayler is doing
uh with microstrategy obviously what
andy and catherine at
the fairfax pensions have done um you
know
again it's just data point after data
point after data point
there is you know a lot of pioneers that
are kind of moving things forward
and ultimately that's what we need right
that's how this uh
ends up being successful and so it's
pretty cool to kind of watch and see
yeah well i think we've got a great
great group of people pushing it forward
um so i think yeah thanks for your hard
work in in that endeavor as well
it's uh it's really great to see the
progress the industry's made
over just the last four years that i've
been involved
absolutely all right ladies and
gentlemen richard
go check out dig diginex and we will
have this against her
thanks palm see you soon